hey everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse RN comm and today I want to
demonstrate for you how to count a
radial pulse before we get started let
me go over some basic things before I
show you the skill your radial pulse is
the most common site use when counting
the pulse rate the reason is is because
it's so easily accessible it's right
there on your wrist counting a pulse
rate tells us a couple things it tells
us the rate the heart rate of a patient
and it tells us the quality so while
you're feeling that pulse rate make sure
you're paying attention to how well it's
pounding for instance is it weak or
thready is it full and bounding is it
normal or is it absent those are all
very important details you need to know
so where is the radial pulse felt it is
found in the groove of the wrist on the
thumb side so right now with me just
fill with your two pads of your finger
your index and your middle finger right
there in the groove where your thumb is
and you can feel the pulse all you have
to do is lightly feel it do not apply
much pressure because if you do you'll
obstruct obstruct the pulse and never
use your thumb when assessing a pulse
because your thumb has a heart beat of
itself and instead of feeling the
patient's pulse you'll be feeling your
own pulse next if a patient has been
active wait about five to ten minutes
before you take their pulse that way
they can get back down to baseline okay
some other tips when taking a pulse
whenever you're taking the pulse
remember to assess if the pulse rate is
regular or irregular because that will
determine how long you will count the
pulse for if the rate is regular you
will count the pulse for 30 seconds and
after 30 seconds you will take that
number and you will multiply it by two
and that will be your pulse rate for
instance say you're feeling a person's
pulse and you counted for 30 seconds and
within that 30 seconds you felt 30
pulsations 30 beats you would take 30
and multiply that by 2 30 times 2 is 60
and that's what their heart rate would
be now if the patient has an irregular
heartbeat
you would have to count the pulse rate
for one full minute to get the most
accurate result so now let me
demonstrate how to count a radial pulse
okay we have our patient and we've
explained the procedure to him about
what we're going to do with County his
pulse rate whenever you have your
patient have them either set down or lie
down here we have him sitting and what
you want to do is you want to have the
elbow bent at least 90 degrees and rest
the hand on his thigh and you will take
the two pads of your finger and you will
fill in the groove of where his wrist is
located where the thumb is you will fill
in the groups with just like I'm doing
so notice I'm not using my thumb I'm
using my index finger and middle finger
and I just have lightly pressed on where
the radial artery is and I will count
each pulsation for 30 seconds his pulse
is regular so I can use the 30 second
rule if it is e regular remember you
have to do it for a minute okay I've
killed it for 30 seconds and his heart
rate I got thirty two and I multiply 32
by two and I got 64 after you take a
patient's pulse always be sure to tell
them what it was and let them know what
normal is which normal is 60 to 100 so
that is how you take a radial pulse
thank you so much for watching and be
sure to check out my other clinical
skill videos and be sure to subscribe to
this YouTube channel thank you